all right let's start today not
hyperbolically but just in a way that
aligns with the facts letting you know
that the polling for the 2022 midterms
in both the House and Senate is looking
a little bit worse for Democrats than it
was uh three weeks ago there was a very
clear although for now not massive shift
away from Democrats towards Republicans
in both the House and Senate and this
just is another reminder that we all
have to vote and we have to take nothing
for granted let's start first with the
House of Representatives Republicans
have been favored to win the house and
they remain favored to win the house but
the the rate uh the probability of that
event taking place has increased and if
we look at the 538
forecast of the House of Representatives
one of the things that you see is that
over time the Democratic chances of
controlling the house surged from about
June through late September and then
started to decline now it is not a
massive change but there is this
inflection point in late September early
October wherein Republican odds of
controlling the house taking control of
the house have increased what do we do
about it well we all have to vote that
doesn't change but this is starting to
look like a trend we then look at the
Senate
Democrats have been for a while and
remain favored to control the Senate
after the midterms to retain control but
again if you look at how those odds have
changed you see an even more notable
inflection point again this was right
around I don't know mid-september and
since mid-september Democratic odds have
declined and Republican odds have
increased this doesn't change that the
most likely outcome the most likely
single outcome is that Democrats retain
control of the Senate and Democrats lose
control of the house that's been the
most statistically likely outcome for a
while now but it's looking a little bit
less good in the in the Senate and even
worse than it was in the house so what
is the takeaway later on in the show
we're going to be looking at more
debates from yesterday we're going to be
looking at other polling and specific
races the takeaway is simply
every single state
has to be fought for
and whether it's looking like an easy
Democratic win so for example there's a
key race in Michigan the governor of
Michigan Gretchen Whitmer the incumbent
trying to beat off a challenge from
Tudor Dixon and Whitmer is up by
somewhere between 8 and 11 points it's
looking pretty safe but that does that
does that mean our michigander viewers
stay home I certainly hope not uh then
you have very very tight races like for
example in Arizona the Arizona
gubernatorial where Kerry Lake the
deranged big lie conspiracy theorist
Republican
is about half a point to one point ahead
of Katie Hobbs that's a disaster do we
stay home there no actually Arizona is
one of the main places as I talked about
yesterday where we we have to make sure
everybody's voting and then there are
other races that are looking more in
favor of Republicans so an example would
be tonight there's a debate in this race
Marco Rubio the incumbent Republican
senator of Florida he is facing a
challenge from uh democratic
congresswoman Val demings he's up like
five or so do we give that one up no
whether the Democrat is up the
Republican is up or it's a tight race
you're allowed to vote so take advantage
and make sure that you do vote and we'll
look in more detail uh at some of these
other races a little bit later when
you're busy during the day and you need
a quick snack sometimes you're just in
the mood for something sweet that's when
I reach for monk Pac our sponsor monk
pack offers GUI granola bars that melt
in your mouth as well as nut and Seed
bars that are perfectly crunchy sweet
and salty but the best part is that each
bar is plant-based with only one gram of
sugar two to three net carbs and only
about 150 calories it's great if you're
doing keto or low carb or like me you
just want to minimize your sugar intake
I can't get enough of dark chocolate
cocoa I'm just a chocolate guy it's
great but they come in other flavors too
like sea salt dark chocolate caramel sea
salt they just launched peanut butter
cocoa chip and dark chocolate cocoa if
you don't love monk pack as much as our
entire team does monk pack will give you
your money back go try monk pack keto
granola bars and nut and Seed bars go to
monkpak.com and use the code Pacman for
20 off the link is down below